i think um justice was done yesterday um
and there was only one conclusion i
think that could be reached after
hearing um the evidence given and
especially from david olisouga as well
um yeah very joyous
obviously uh do you believe that it
should have gone to court in the first
place because from what you're
suggesting you you believe that that
they were absolutely correct in what
they did
i just think it was a waste of the
taxpayers money um you know there were
10 000 people marched that day and
obviously what we can see from video
footage there are many people who took
part um in toppling colston that day so
to
to you know to
point out four people for them to stand
trial for ten thousand people it should
never have happened um and you know
justice was served yesterday and they
are um not guilty which is great news
we would be potentially uh talking about
a very different case had somebody been
injured while that that statue was
toppled thankfully nobody was but if if
that were the case would you still say
that that their actions were correct i
think that's by the by and it's just
totally totally pointless question to
ask nobody was hurt
um what happened happened everybody was
safe the only person um or the object
that was destroyed that day was edward
costume he was thrown into the river
where he had thrown thousands of
enslaved people into the river
so you know i'm not going to go down
that road of a health and safety point
of view because it's just
okay but you don't think potentially
that it was it could have been a
dangerous situation no so i'm not gonna
sit here and argue the case about
potentially being dangerous nobody was
hurt or injured that day so and i've you
know said what i have to say with
regards that i'm not gonna go down this
road of a health and safety matter
the uh government minister grant shap
says britain's not a country where
destroying public property can ever be
acceptable how would you respond to that
um i think you know i think probably the
question that should be asked is
what can be done so this doesn't happen
again
let's start looking at statues and
monuments
and what those p who those people are
what they stand for
are that you know does it include
everybody does it exclude some people
i think that's probably the more
important question that people should
ask themselves rather than you know does
this give people a right to do this how
about thinking to people thinking to
themselves what drove these people to do
what they did and then addressing that
rather than um this
divisive narrative that i've heard over
the last two days um you know let's
people start coming together and ask why
people felt that they had to take
matters into their own hands and do what
they did
and why do you think that is
that people had to take matters into
their own hands um
you know it's
as as we all know
there was a petition
for years um asking for colson to be
removed it fell on deaf ears
um and people took matters into their
own hands but what we can't do is forget
why 10 000 people marched in bristol
that day
and that's because of george floyd
and the death that he suffered at the
hands of the police and that cannot be
lost in any of this narrative no of
course of course but we know that that
the statue of edward callston has been a
contentious statue as you say rightly
for many years why do you think it is
that bristol council wasn't able to take
into account that the wishes of many
people to see that statue removed
um i think that might have something to
do with the uh merchandise and them
having a say
in the democratic process in bristol
um and what this has highlighted is the
merch adventurers who had objected to
the statue of edward colston being
removed
um
he's gone now i think there are a lot of
other
um things that that need to go you know
the street names etc and we need to
concentrate on that and but you know
we're not erasing history history is now
being told in its full context you know
there are plenty of museums around to if
people want to to know history in its
full context where you know objects and
things like that should be
uh we know that a replacement uh statue
was erected for some time a statue of
your your good self what was the
thinking behind that well i think it was
just to commemorate the day of the 10
000 people who marched in bristol you
know i i took to that plinth and raised
my fist in a black power salute i'd
dress as a black panther because as far
as i was concerned not much has changed
black people are still being killed at
the hands of the police
um and you know it stood for 24 hours it
served its purpose i think the fact that
it was there for 24 hours uh made a had
a bigger effect um it being taken down
because it what it did is it
gathered more conversation and
conversations kept on happening and they
still are and here we are now we're
still having those conversations
just very quickly we're running out of
time i just wonder if you you might um
have a suggestion as to who you would
like to see on the plinth permanently
i have no suggestion as to who should be
on that plinth um what i do know is that
bristol city council
need to do something to commemorate the
enslaved um
and
whether that's somebody on the plinth or
or some build something bigger than that
that's what needs to be addressed
apparently there's a history commission
that's been put in place by the mayor
marvin reese
and let's just hope they stick to their
word and more action and less talking
generally thank you very much for
speaking to us this afternoon and
sharing your views with us thank you
that's great thank you